when many people talk about the
cryptocurrency industry they lump
everything together they simply say what
are all the assets all those 19 000
cryptocurrencies they must all be the
same right well that's not really true
and ultimately there's only one asset
that has the regulatory clarity that's
bitcoin it has already been stated by
the sec the cftc and other regulatory
bodies around the world the bitcoin is
not a security and that clarity has
allowed not only for large financial
institutions to come in buy the asset
and hold it they offer it to their
clients but it also has allowed public
companies to actually put bitcoin on
their balance sheets and so when you
look at regulatory clarity it serves as
a tailwind for these assets but now the
question turns what about the rest of
the industry those 19 000
cryptocurrencies there isn't any clarity
michael saylor was recently on cnn with
julia chatterley and he was asked what
do you think is going to happen is
clarity good for the industry here's
what michael said does bitcoin go back
up and does it take regulation of all
kinds
to to get us there to rule out some of
the obvious criticisms that have been
been pushed over the last
two months
yeah i i think it's it's clear the
people are confused and regulation will
be constructive because clarity will
help the market mature uh the people are
confused about what's a currency what's
a commodity what's security what are
tokens there's 19 000 cryptos out there
i think we can see in the crypto crash
that that the average investor has been
taken advantage of by traders and by
wildcat crypto banks
and
as the regulators come in and they clear
up this confusion and they introduce
rules of the road it's going to be good
for mainstream investors it's going to
be good for corporations it'll be it
will catapult the industry from
the entrepreneurial offshore anything
goes stage into
into a institutional mature
asset class now michael's got a great
point here that as we get more clarity
it'll actually serve as a boom for the
industry there's been a lot of problems
there was built up leverage there's
plenty of people who are misleading
their customers or investors as we get
more regulatory clarity some of that
coming in more disclosures some of it
coming in the prevention of allowing
people to do nefarious things
it likely will give the confidence to
many investors both retail and
institutional to come into the space it
will also elicit more entrepreneurs to
come in and start to build products and
services that allow for the global
adoption of these technologies bitcoin
is a decentralized neutral technology it
does not enrich the creator in any way
simply bitcoin continues to execute code
just free speech in a way that allows
anyone in the world to move words around
that's unique to bitcoin there was no
pre-mine for the team
there was no enrichment of the founders
there was no sale of fundraising to be
able to finance the project that's why
the sec and cftc have said that bitcoin
is not a security and it's likely going
to be a different outcome for many many
other projects in the space
that doesn't mean that they'll
necessarily all go away just means that
they'll have to conform to the
securities laws in their various
jurisdictions
and ultimately as we get more regulatory
clarity more people will start to
actually come into the bitcoin industry
but come into the crypto industry too
they simply want to understand what are
the rules of the road and then they'll
abide by them
regulatory clarity is going to be good
for the industry but just remember that
clarity doesn't mean you get the rules
that you want it simply means that
everyone
now understands what the rules are and
if you break the rules you'll get in
trouble the need for regulatory clarity
is starting to heat up we've seen many
many
historic collapses some in tokens some
in ecosystems and some in funds
obviously regulators politicians and
many other people in positions of
oversight
they're salivating to try to get their
hands around this industry so they can
create rules of the road that everyone
has to follow bitcoin is not a security
continues to grow even though the price
has come down as we get more and more
regulatory clarity i think many
investors entrepreneurs and market
participants will come to the conclusion
that bitcoin is the signal among a lot
of noise